think you're so much better than
everybody I got news for you bro you're
the one who's not a queen at least I got
potential and then I'm gonna walk by
next time you give me that look I'ma
smack it off your face okay come down
from your Tower when you're ready to
play with the real pieces getting the
work done okay come down from your Tower
when you're tired of just looking good
you'd rather look good and lose than
look bad and win
okay that's the difference between us
I'm willing to sacrifice and do whatever
it takes to get the job done you just
want all the credit I could be anyone
you never know what I could become
better watch your back